[Musique]
il a été élu maire à 26 ans député à 29
mon invité est un jeune homme pressé qui
ne s'embarrasse pas forcément des
manières en politique son ambition
changer le logiciel de la
[Musique]
droite bonjour pierreenri Dumont bonjour
Alors qui sont de nous regarder ou de
nous écouter en podcast vont me maudir
parce qu'on va commencer cette émission
par une chanson qui a tendance à rester
dans la tête toute la journée vous voyez
de quoi je parle VO très bien bon c'est
le fameux lipd des jeunes de l'UMP qui a
été lancé fin 2009 et vous allez sans
doute reconnaître l'un des
[Musique]
interprètes alors on a reconnu
Rach
ramaade mais on s'est permis de faire
aussi un arrêt sur image sur un un jeune
homme l'un des interprètes on le voit
ici en train de taper sur un un jump B
vous le reconnaissez oui bah c'était mes
années militantes c'est vrai que ça
reste un beau souvenir bon il y a eu un
un BAT de buzz sur sur mais non non au
final donc beaucoup de gens s'en sont un
peu moqués on va dire ouis mais mais au
final on a pris vraiment énormément de
plaisir à le tourner il y a eu un
décalage dans dans la diffusion ça doit
être diffusé à l'issue à la fin des 3
jours du campus des jeunes où on partait
la dans le train donc c'est le train
aller ça a été diffusé 3 mois après au
moment des fêtes de Noël entre-temps la
crise financière est arrivée donc
évidemment le contexte était pas le même
clim avait changé mais honnêtement c'est
aussi un symbole des années jeune pop
qui on est un grand mouvement jeune
30000 jeunes alors à l'époque vous étiez
vous aviez 22 ans vous aviez déjà des
responsabilités au sein du mouvement des
des Jeunes Populaires de l'UMP vous avez
pris votre carte à l'UMP à 17 ans
qu'est-ce qui peut motiver un adolescent
comme ça à s'engager dans un parti
politique aussi jeune euh une
personnalité c'est C Nicolas Sarkozi son
dynamisme moi je me souviens de de jou
que je regardais à la télévision chez
moi quand j'étais encore un peu plus
jeune mais quand Taric Ramadan quand
Jean Marie Le Pen où il écrasé le match
et c'était ce dynamisme cette volonté
cette envie de changement de faire qui
qui moi m'a m'a vraiment appé et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris ma carte c'est
pour Nicolas Sarkozi alors il y a aussi
il y avait un Terrero familial qui était
propice on va dire vos parents vous ont
un peu fait baigner dans la la culture
gouliste RPR c'est ça oui mais mes
parents étaient tous les deux des des
adhérents RPR ils sont pour certains ont
été candidats à des élections on voit là
la photo de mon père qui était Candat je
crois c une cantonnale en 82 ou 83 dans
un canton de de
Calais et donc on l'appelait lege valesa
à l'époque c'est vratit côté Val avec la
mouache et et donc du coup oui c'était
un terro RPR militant vous allez même
aux réunion des du RPR à 7 ans c'était
oui c'était l'anecdote mais avec le
t-shirt les jeunes avec Chirac voilà
lors des soirées électorales c la soirée
électorale de 95 du coup d'élection
présidentielle de 95 et en effet je me
suis retrouvé avec un t-irt les jeunes
avec Chirac dans un un garage de caléis
qui avait été loué à l'occasion pour
faire une permanence de campagne locale
pour les élections présidentielles donc
oui j'ai baigné dans un terro qui est un
terro RPR de droite euh mais par des
parents qui voilà incarneent aussi cette
envie de travailler de toujours faire
plus qui ont créé leurs propres
entreprises qui sont partis quasiment de
rien et qui ont réussi donc c'est aussi
cette tradition cette histoire familiale
que je cherche à à honorer par mon
engagement tique et alors sur le papier
vous avez un parcours qui est assez
classique he il y a les Jeunes Pop on
l'a vu il y a eu Science Po Paris vous
avez ét aussi collaborateur d'un d'un
député à l'Assemblée mais vous dites que
votre parcours il est devenu aujourd'hui
une exception pour les gens issus des
classes moyennes comme vous et vous en
faites d'ailleurs un combat politique
qui est un peu au cœur de votre
engagement oui c'est vraiment l'angle
que je prends et la ligne directrice que
je me fixe pour mon engagement politique
c'est faire en sorte que n'importe quel
gamin en particulier chez moi dans dans
le Pas de Calais à Calais dans le
calaisy la ruralité qui a envie de faire
des études supérieures quel que soit ces
des études supérieures soit en mesure de
pouvoir le faire il faut pas que
l'argent le milieu familial soit un
frein il demande évidemment être bien
orienté mais il y a aussi une question
de moyens il y a une question de moyens
public les lycées chez moi il forment
pas à rentrer dans des classes prépa il
forment pas à passer des concours ou
quand vous avez dit au lycé que vous
vouliez faire Sciences Po on a compris
la fac de science polique politique
l'école à Paris exactement et et donc du
coup moi ce que je dis c'est que il faut
déjà que tous les lycées forment aux
mêmes choses c'estàd pas simplement
avoir le bac mais préparer les études
supérieures mais audelà de ça il faut
que là où on peut aider c'est ce que
j'ai fait par exemple dans ma commune de
marquencalisie quand j'étais maire et on
a continué à mettre en place ce système
quand un gamin de la ville veut aller
faire des études en Erasmus à l'étranger
que les parents peuvent pas payer on
peut donner des bourses qui vont jusqu'à
10000 € on aide le permis de conduire on
aide à passer le BAFA c'està dire que en
gros on donne les moyens aux jeunes de
se réaliser alors il y a une nouvelle
étape dans votre engagement en politique
franchi en 2014 vous vous êtes présenté
à la mairie de Marc près de de Calais
c'est une ville qui est historiquement
ancrée à gauche vos parents ont été
convaincu que vous alliez perdre et vous
pendant toute la campagne vous avez
martelé que vous étiez le candidat le
plus compétent à 26 ans il faut un sacré
culot pour faire ça parce que vous avez
été élu hein
oui c'est j'aiété élu on voit là c'est
le conseil municipal d'installation en
en mars 2014 j'ai été élu parce que les
habitants de la ville m'ont fait
confiance voilà c'est en effet une ville
qui était historiquement de gauche mais
dire à 26 ans c'est moi le plus
compétent il a pas une part non c'est
factuel c'est-à-dire que j'étais face à
des personnes don qui avaient fait le
travail de la ville la ville c'est bien
développé mais qui commençait à stagner
se transformer progressivement en cité
d'ortoir on pour être très clair moi
j'éis arrivé avec un autre programme et
puis en effet il faut quand même
évidemment un peu un peu de culot pour
pour arriver débarquer comme ça moi
c'est ma ville natale c'est là où j'ai
grandi je faisais des allers-retours
parce que forcément je travaillais à
Paris la semaine mais mais c'était
vraiment une belle aventure et
honnêtement le mandat de maire est le
plus beau mandat qu'on peut exercer dans
la République française c'est là où on
est vraiment au prisme avec les besoins
du territoire c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que quand j'ai été élu député en 2017
j'ai gardé mon mandat de conseiller
municipal et j'ai abandonné le mandat de
conseiller départemental alors Duculot
vous en avez eu aussi lors de vos
premiers vœux en tant que maire de Marc
vous avez convié tous les élus de
l'agglomération et et vous leur êtes
rentré dedans assez violemment on voit
les articles de presse de l'époque ça a
fait un peu la une des journaux
localement c'est votre style en
politique on on cogne d'abord on discute
après éventuellement c'est ça c'est ma
ma ma devise en politique c'est d'abord
on gueule et après on discute et là et
là c'est efficaceah c'est c'est plutôt
efficace parce que je vais vous dire ce
qui s'est passé après la cérémonie des
vœux j'ai visé trois euh trois trois
cibles la première cible c'était le
président d'agglomération de l'époque
qui avait augmenté les impôts des
ménages alors que moi dans ma ville je
l'ai diminué donc les habitants benah
disaient attendez Monsieur le Maire on
voit pas la différence parce que pour
eux ça revient au même et d'ailleurs on
s'est aperçu après des rapports après
des discussions avec les élu qu'il y
avait en effet de la cavalerie
budgétaire donc j'ai soulevé un lièvre à
ce moment-là qui a coûté sa place au
président d'agglomération on est arriv
arrivé au point où ne pouvait plus
investir tous les investissements dans
l'agglomération avaient été gelés à
cause de l'explosion de dépenses de
fonctionnement sur la question de de
l'État et de la ville de calis à côté
moi j'avais mis en doute la création du
camp julferry qui a mené quelques mois
plus tard à la création de la fameuse
jungle à Calais qui é à la frontière
entre Calais et Marc 10000 personnes
dans un bidonville j'avais alerté sur le
fait que ça allait devenir ce que c'est
devenu et donc j'ai pas forcément tort
dans ce que j'avais dit malheureusement
al on a vu vos premiers vœux assez
musclés en tant que maire en 2017 à
peine élu député vous avez aussi un peu
secouer le le cocotier mais cette fois
dans votre propre parti avec l'ambition
bah de prendre la place des anciens on
va dire votre mot d'ordre c'est un peu
place aux jeunes c'est c'est c'est une
forme de dégagisme presque non c'est pas
place aux jeunes c'est de dire que tout
le monde doit trouver sa place et que
c'est pas parce qu'on vient d'être élu
que qu'on qu'on débarque un peu de
territoire où il y avait jamais eu
d'élus auparavant ou très très peu que
ce soit moi dans pascalé que ce soit
Aurélien dans l'autre que ce soit
d'autre que que ce qu'on dit est pas
moins vrai que ceux qui sont présents
depuis longtemps donc l'enjeu c'est
maintenant en effet maintenant qu'on a
un peu vieilli tous pris un peu plus
d'assurance encore c'est de pouvoir
expliquer que bah le logiciel de la
droite doit changer qu'on doit pas
parler simplement aux classes moyenne
supérieurure et aux personnesraité mais
que on a tout un un terau de gens de
droite qui sont nous nos électeurs dans
nos circonscriptions qui sont des gens
qui croient dans la valeur travail qui
se lèvent tout le matin pour travailler
qui gagnent pas des mers des C qui
roulent pas sur l'or et qui ont besoin
de propositions de texte de la droite
donc c'est cette c'est cette idée là
c'est ce projet
politique là que vous portez vous les
les jeunes trentenaires parce que vous
formez un petit groupe en fait au sein
du du groupe les républicains
euh il y a qui d'ailleurs dans dans dans
ce groupe ah bah il y a plusieurs
personnes c'est principalement des
personnes qu'on connaissait déjà avant
de venir à l'Assemblée nationale parce
que c'était dans les réseaux les terau
Jeunes Populaires à l'époque on en voit
certains sur les photos ça c'est la
précédente législature mais euh c'est
fait par bon évidemment Julien di qui
était responsable départemental des
Jeunes de l'INE com moi j'étais dans le
pas decalis on a Aurélien évidemment
dans le lotte Yan dans dans le
territoire
deà on est un petit groupe
géographiquement on est déjà avec nos
bureau côte à côe depuis le précédent
mandat et puis après on s'entend bien
parce que voilà on partage à âge des
territoires qui sont pas des territoire
évident qui ont à peu près les mêmes
caractéristiques d'un point de vue
sociologique et puis ce côté un peu on
est on est débarqué de nulle part et on
essaye d'imposer un style peut-être un
peu différent mais on en a besoin
aujourd'hui la droite c'est quoi c'est
moins de 5 % l'élection présidentiell
donc soit on décide de continuer comme
on fait depuis 15 ans à savoir dire
toujours les mêmes choses et se
retrouver dans une situation où on
nintéresse plus personne soit on essaie
de légèrement changer le logiciel faire
comprendre que la population et les
Françaises et les Français ont évolué et
que la droite doit pouvoir toujours en
gardant ses valeurs chevillé au corps
proposer autre chose que ce qu'elle a pu
proposer je pense que le paroxisme
c'était la question de la réforme des
retraites ou la réforme des retraites on
avait vraiment un axe sur la question
des des carrière longue pourquoi c'est
pas pour embêter le parti pour embêter
la droite c'est simplement pour dire que
nous on va pas commencer par pénaliser
ceux qui ont commencé en apprentissage
ceux qui ont commencé le plus tôt et pas
pénaliser les cadres et les cadres sub
ceux qui ont fait les plus longues
études tant mieux pour eux qui gagne le
plus tant mieux pour eux mais on peut
pas avoir un de poid de mesure donc
c'est cette idée de renouer avec les
classes populaires qui a fait que dans
ce petit groupe là vous avez tous je
crois hein voter la motion de censure
contre le gouverneur contre le
gouvernement à l'occasion de cette
réforme des retraites euh c'est pas très
réglot parce que vous avez pas respecté
la consigne qui avait été adoptée à la
majorité au sein de votre groupe oui
mais la Constitution dispose qu'il n'y a
pas demander impératif ouais mais enfin
la politique c'est c'est aussi respecter
un collectif respecter le fait
majoritaire oui non mais moi
l'engagement que j'avais pris devant mes
devant mes habitants c'est celui j'avais
écrit noir sur blanc lors de ma campagne
électorale moi j'ai respecté mon
engagement pris devant mes électeurs et
j'ai pas pris un engagement devant mon
groupe d'abord les électeurs ensuite le
groupe on va passer à notre quiz à
présent le principe est assez simple je
vais vous proposer des phrases et vous
allez devoir les compléter c'est bon
pour vous allez rien de tel qu'une
partie de FIFA pour tisser le lien avec
les jeunes et pour se détendre ouais
parce qu'en fait vous à plusieurs
reprises vous avez organisé comme ça des
défis vous avez défié les jeunes de
votre circonscription venez défier votre
député à FIFA ça marche vraiment vous
arri à les intéresser à la politique
comme ça ça marche pas ouais alors les
intéressé à la politique oui et non mais
en tout cas on peut échanger sur leur
quotidien et donc moi ça me donne des
bit pour comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que jeêtre jeune mais ça fait
quand même longtemps que j'ai pas mis
les pieds dans une classe de BTS et
cetera donc c'est aussi le moyen de
pouvoir savoir ce qui se passe échanger
de façon plus plus détendue quand les
sénateurs de droite me qualifient de
sale gosse ils ont parfaitement
raison vous êtes un sal gosse vous
l'assumez oui mais je je suis un sal
gosse mais parce ils ont dit ça quand
vous avez voulu aligner leur régime de
retraite sur celui des députés c'est ça
oui bah ce qui est normal et je le
referai aujourd'hui bien sûr enfin si je
fais trois mandats de députés est-ce
qu'il y en aura un 4e c'est pas à moi de
le décider vous aviez pris un engagement
en 2017 vous aviez dit deux ou trois
mandats maximum ouais ou oui c'est c'est
vrai non parce que l'envie de faire
autre chose est toujours toujours
présente euh député ça prend du temps ça
prend du temps sur la vie privé familial
sincèrement et je vais arriver à un âge
après déjà à la fin de ce mandat
j'aurais passé les je procherai les 40
ans ou là et donc non non mais mais mais
non mais voilà enfin je suis pas marié
j'ai pas d'enfants j'ai aussi besoin de
construire une vie privée familialeut et
donc c'est une question non mais c'est
une question qui moi me tarode mais
tarode aussi beaucoup de députés de ma
génération parce que quand on est arrivé
à l'Assemblée on était pas marié sans
enfants contrairement à des députés
d'autres législatures qui eux venaient
en fin ou en milieu de parcours
politique où ils avaient déjà construit
une vie familiale avant merci beaucoup
Pierre-Henri du monde d'êt venu dans la
politique et
[Musique]
moi